okay do you guys remember your very
first earthquake experience
yeah yeah yeah that was because okay
we're from the uk yeah it is literally
the safest place on earth
yeah yeah i was about to say you guys
don't get earthquakes all right no no
we're like we are like the furthest away
from like any fault line of like any
country
like we were like natural disasters in
the uk
is like non-existent it's like running
out of tea like that
england is so [ __ ] safe you have to
try really hard
to get yourself killed in england by
nature yeah you really do have to go out
of your way
yeah because because australia we don't
have earthquakes at all
or anything but everything else would
just be well we have you know bushfires
and stuff like that and of course our
animals are just out for blood but you
guys don't even have
dangerous animals right no we don't
right that's why i'm convinced there's
so many like famous british explorers
because they must have been so
[ __ ] bored of the uk like oh it's
another [ __ ] squirrel
who'da thought
talking to americans and canadians who
go camping and they have to worry about
bears and stuff like that and i remember
going camping in england and i'm just
like
oh yeah like i guess we have to worry
about deers i guess deers can be
dangerous
and i feel like the biggest war in the
uk is how much alcohol do i burn
like how much alcohol is the right
amount of alcohol how much alcohol and
toilet paper do i bring
yeah that's always the worry so it's
like i gotta carry two liters of water
10 liters of alcohol so we gotta try and
bounce this out somehow
yeah i don't know i remember my very
first earthquake experience wasn't in
japan
it was actually in america during ax oh
yeah
it's 28 well not last year now yeah oh
no it is last yeah last
year yeah last year's ax so 2019 ax and
i remember
i remember it was your first one yeah
that was like my very first really
yeah wow so yeah to explain when we were
at ax last year we went through a
magnitude is it seven it was
six or seven but it's far away so it
wasn't yeah awful but it was still
i mean we were it still is the strongest
earthquake i've been
in even after moving japanese yeah yeah
and i remember i was on like the
64. and it's
it's it was like such a humbling
experience because at first
i didn't know what was going on because
i i
i i remember standing up and i felt a
bit dizzy and i was like
what the [ __ ] going on am i just like
really fatigued am i hungover what's
going on
so i go i go up to the window right just
imagine you're going up to the window on
the 64th floor of a skyscraper
and then you look down and then you see
the [ __ ] building just shift
like that and it was just like this
like i immediately i've never felt
vertigo so fast and i immediately just
pinned myself against the wall
just being like [ __ ] [ __ ] this is an
earthquake
i'm surprised you had the balls to go
towards the window
because i didn't know it was an
earthquake i just thought i was just
dizzy
or drunk or something i mean the first
one because it was like
three that weekend yeah no there's two
in the it was in the same day
yeah so the first one i was in the
elevator while it was happening
and the elevator was shaking a lot more
than i thought it should have been
shaking
right and i'm pretty sure there's a
japanese woman in there who was from one
of the stanzas yeah
and she looked [ __ ] terrified oh yeah
and i was like
we're nearly near the bottom i'm sure it
will be fine
we're like 10 floors i'm sure we got
this but then the second one was with
you yeah yeah that was so funny
do you want to tell that story you
should tell you okay okay so the second
earthquake that happened i think it was
only
maybe a couple of hours after was it
yeah yeah i think it was like rushed to
your hotel room because i was busy
that's right
that was like that night yeah it was it
was you me aki and our friend nabi
and we were just chilling in our hotel
room we were just talking about what we
were going to do that night because i
think
we're going to a party we're going to go
to a party and so we were just chilling
before the party started
and you know the second earthquake comes
through and it was i think it was
stronger than the first one wasn't it i
think so something like that but either
way very strongly at least magnitude 6
from what i remember i think it was 7.1
though i think that was the 7 wasn't it
yeah
and uh and of course it was an
earthquake i'm used to it
uh obviously everybody else wasn't yeah
so
we quickly ran out and we were at the
very very top of the thing was like the
68th or 69th yeah or something of that
of that hotel
and and even amidst all the panic
connor and my friend navi they were
eating uh i was saying chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a
like chick-fil-a nuggets and connor and
nabi just kind of looked at each other
and went
well if i'm gonna die might as well
finish off these nuggets
like everyone was panicking i remember
there was literally that like
stereotypical american family there's
one dude one like white guy with like
three
daughters like get get down to the floor
get down to the bottom floor dardis i'm
gonna i'm gonna direct you and i'm there
with like my nuggets walking past him
slightly like i mean it's
it's mine i got about yeah if i'm gonna
die at least i'm gonna die with nugs in
my hands
we were like rushing down the stairs we
got like 20 floors down i was like i'm
not you know what
i i don't want to do any more physical
exercise i think
i think i've done enough so yeah i did a
move which is probably not a pro gamer
move i was like you know what
the shaking stopped like two minutes ago
i'mma get the elevator
there is 50 more floors and i would
rather die literally than get these
stairs
and i went to the elevator but the weird
configuration of this hotel
you had to go back to the top yeah
yeah so that means then i was like all
right well the elevators are still
working they should have been stopped
they were still working so i was like
okay so i go back from the 50th floor
which i just walked down
from the 70th i walked all the way down
and i was like okay i'm going to go back
up to the 70th floor
i go to get the elevator to go all the
way down and they're blocking it off
yeah they're like you can't go until
it's safe and i'm like
[ __ ] meanwhile our other friend was just
like [ __ ] i'm getting walking
all the way down this way all the way
down he's just waiting at the bottom and
he calls me he's like
where are you are you guys alive because
i convinced them i'm like listen guys
you guys can keep walking i'm getting
the elevator and then they were like
okay no i came with you yeah yeah yeah i
was just like well great we're back i
guess we
ran down 24's for no reason it was so
scary though because i remember
i was a little i wasn't worried because
you know the doors were closing and
opening on their own i thought that's
okay i can deal with that and what i
didn't
like anticipate was when i looked out
the building i could literally see the
building opposite us we were going like
this yeah yeah like parallaxing yeah
yeah and i was like
oh that's not right like
buildings shouldn't do that because i
remember it was it was like to me
it was a really humbling experience just
at that moment
i was like my life is not in my own
hands yeah like if this building
collapses
there is literally nothing i can do
because you know when you feel like
something bad happens you feel like you
have some
some kind of control like you might see
a car coming and you you think you know
maybe i can jump out of the way of this
there was like if the building was just
falls like logically i knew this
building was designed
to withstand earthquakes but in my heart
i was like
okay at this moment i'm just putting my
faith in the engineers and the builders
that they've done their job [ __ ]
correctly because if they haven't i'm
dead
and there's literally nothing i can do
about it
and i i i guess that was like a first
for me you know i i i'd never been in
that kind of situation where i had just
my my life was in the was in the hands
of like completely something some other
external to be fair i've experienced a
lot of earthquakes in my life but
being on the 69th 17th floor was
definitely a first for me yeah
you know i've been on you know apart
i've been in apartment buildings that
are like
10 20 floors high and that was still
scary because again the whole thing is
shaking i
have to keep telling myself it's good
that it's shaking it's good that it's
shaking
um but my first i think the scariest
earthquake experience i had was uh it
was in japan obviously
um and it was up north where my grandma
lives right um and it was where you know
the giant
earthquake of 2011 hit essentially so
that is that place is like a hot spot
massive earthquakes um and uh and i was
there i was in some kind of like uh dvd
rental place
like a really old dvd rental place near
there with my sister and
suddenly i think it was like an attitude
seven and a half or something like that
really really big it was so big in fact
that all of the dvds and books on the
shelves just
flew out oh wow and me and i had to like
grab my sister's hand and just [ __ ]
get the hell out of there
wow and but we couldn't go all the way
out because the shop assistant was like
don't go out into the street because if
a street if a [ __ ] falls then you're
dead yeah so we had to kind of
stand in the door frame or off the shop
and just kind of
wait for it to settle down and yeah that
was definitely a lot scarier because
being on i thought being on a building
was scary being on the ground floor
like on the street in something that big
is really scary because people running
out and i thought that's kind of dumb
because the building's really safe
yeah yeah yeah running out you don't
know what could like what could fall
exactly or you know if a traffic light
or a you know a street light
falls on you then you know i think it's
that sense of control you know that yeah
i think you have even though
statistically you you are actually safer
in the building yeah the buildings are
designed at least the newer ones i think
like i mean that was a
really big hotel and it's mainly
designed for like 13 magnitude
earthquakes yeah like
they're pretty [ __ ] sturdy